hi linda how are you doing nice jacket i
was just going to say we got the memo on
the blazer look yeah we and we got the
demo on the on the on the good colors
yes definitely you have the necklaces
going on though i'm jealous they look
beautiful
thank
uh such a pleasure getting to talk to
you first of all human and divine you
know the original song came out it was
so beautiful so moving i know it was
dedicated to your late husband why was
that song perfect to dedicate to him
[Applause]
uh i was married to
my best friend and
one of the
um
if
if
if you were a friend of his you were
really one of the luckiest people in the
world
and uh the loss of him was uh
devastating this past year
but i wrote it while he was alive and uh
i had
i had been in front of my little book
that i write in and and uh
i i was trying to
describe what la
love was i was trying to
uh we were on a you know on the plane
and and
i was just looking at him i'm trying to
figure out what it is
without it being
religious
without it being uh
a assigning
love to any deity or
or to another person but within yourself
that you feel
if they're you know if there is a god
that that's the
that's what that feels like
love
you know that's what that feels like
love and forgiveness
within it
well your voice is so beautiful on it
the lyrics are gorgeous so you have this
beautiful ballad and then we hear this
amazing remix which kind of has a bond
theme mixed
hanging out in the club i love it so
much what inspired the remix
well this is dave on day dave monday is
i know he's heard it before audacious
uh
uh
and he
i had heard so much about him he had
done it has had so many hit uh records
in
in the remix world and
we've done everyone from gaga to rihanna
to
uh um
it's a whole list of uh really amazing
people
and
and to have someone take your work and
the original work
and turn it into something else
it is a little scary yeah and what he
did is that he kept he kept the um
the feeling of the song
and so i was it was throwing caution to
the wind and it felt great
i love it was it your idea to remix the
song
no it wasn't it was um uh it was
my
my agent my my manager
and uh and then
she talked us into to in the record
company and and uh
to do a remix and
and we found dave all day and
because of his talent i we're really
thrilled with it it's so good
you know you mentioned names like lady
lady gaga you know rihanna is there an
artist that you would love to
collaborate with on a new single because
i could see you and gaga making magic
it you know the collaboration is
probably
the best part of writing and the best
part of performing is the collaboration
every time you're on stage you're
collaborating because the music is never
the same which is why you need to go to
uh live performances you never know
what's going to happen in a live
performance you never know it's always
just a little bit different it's always
a little bit uh you know one thing or
another i know that billy joel laughs
because he always forgets the lyrics to
his songs
he never he always remembers the chords
and and always has to have the lyrics
right there uh
they're various little things that we
all do uh that you know when i when i
forget lyrics i just make them up
even to well-known songs so uh i i i
love performing live um and but
recording is also uh writing and
recording in this collaborative way is
wonderful
and now i have a new way to collaborate
and that's with dave all day so he's he
is waiting in the wings for another song
that i've i've just about to finish and
uh
and i hope he likes it enough to want to
uh do that one too so we'll see oh that
is a good tease that is very exciting
because i know your fans that was going
to be one of my next questions are we
going to get more music like this you
know uh from the original version to
this remix
fans i'm sure you you saw people writing
this online and even myself it
definitely has that that bond theme
which got me thinking had you ever been
approached to be a bond girl and is that
something you would have been interested
in doing
uh yeah well yes i actually was
approached my agent was i was approached
to being a blonde girl uh i didn't get
the part because someone else
but i think that i was
filming wonder woman at the time
so
um
would love to see that
you would have been amazing
that was uh
too bad um
that was back then i think it would have
been sean
connery yeah
right
that's okay you just you know we're busy
doing an iconic role like wonder woman
um
is it true that you had 25 dollars in
your bank account at the time you got
the roll that's what yes
i only had 25
left in my bank account i was thinking
how am i going to pay and how am i going
to pay
you know my insurance and i owned the
car
uh there were no cell phones back then
so you know
uh
but
yeah i got the roll then
well
the transitional spin obviously is so
iconic
and i just learned this you were
responsible for coming up with the idea
of the spin
yeah
they didn't know that
yeah they were trying to figure out
how
to transform wonder woman because
it wasn't depicted in the comic book
evidently
and uh
uh
and
you know she just appeared as wonder
woman
and so
uh they
thought about turning her
but they had a lazy susan and i said
well
why don't i just do a
do a dancer's turn you know just do a
spin and they said
okay that's amazing and there you go
there you go there it is